everybody's John Stewart welcome to your
weekly ticket checkout on new film
irresistible lavell one thing dango now
starting on June 26 but before we talk
to the cast of irresistable about their
new film here is the top movie news
Michael Mann's new Ferrari film has been
greenlit and Hugh Jackman is in talks to
star as the racing icon Enzo Ferrari the
film takes place in the summer of 1957
when all the dynamic forces in Enzo
Ferraris life collide the race car
company he and his wife Laura built is
going broke
so Enzo boldly rolls the dice for all
their futures on one race 1000 miles
across Italy and Edgar Wright is working
on a new film entitled the chain the
thriller is centered on a woman who
learns that her 11 year old daughter has
been kidnapped
and discovers that the only way to get
her back is to pay a ransom and kidnap
another child her daughter will be
released only when the next victim's
parents kidnapped another child Oh cuz
it's a chain anyway next story it looks
like there's a third Mamma Mia in the
works judy kramer who produced both the
2008 film adaptation and it's 2018
sequel says a third film is in the works
in an interview with The Daily Mail she
said she was meaning to be working on it
but got delayed due to cope at 19 Kramer
went on to say I think one day there
will be another film because they're
meant to be a trilogy you see I know
Universal would like me to do it
Kramer also teased that she would like
to use some of the new songs Abba has
written that will apparently debut later
this year irresistible which is
available to watch June 26th is a comedy
about what happens when a small
Wisconsin town becomes the main
attraction of a political circus when a
Democratic strategist helps a retired
veteran run for mayor I chatted with the
film's writer and director Jon Stewart
as well as Rose Byrne Chris Cooper and
Mackenzie Davis all about their latest
project check it out my first question
is this film is set in
a small-town why do you think it was
important to tackle like someone like
politics in a small town for this film
um you know in some respects it could
have been set anywhere it's really more
about how the system around elections no
longer serves the citizens that it
purports to serve so the setting had
more to do with kind of playing into the
political divide that we have in this
country so that you the story has some
credibility as you begin to watch it so
you kind of forget so that at the end
when you reveal kind of the real purpose
of the movie yours to get kind of the
idea that to have the audience believe
they're watching a different movie than
the one that they're actually watching
and so it had to exist in a way that I
think the audience believes could happen
could play into the narratives that
we've been fed one of my favorite
moments from from your character from
faith is when she's on like the video
called doing her television interview
and she just has a very like straight
like stoic face and a very stiff
politician face where did where did that
come from where did that inspiration
come from you know I've always been a
fan of the genre of sort of films about
the media films about politics whether
it's broadcast news or the newsroom that
recent Apple show it's such a great
backdrop for drama and theatrics
and there's a specific tone with with
the with the job that I think is
required and I was fascinated to try to
capture that and it's very
nerve-wracking to be honest because of
the politico speak is like another
language it really is and I don't know
it so I was desperately trying to there
is a almost of boredom or a dullness
sometimes when people win there and they
just don't draw breath that's the other
thing
breath saying is no effort so I try to
capture that while whilst you know
knowing that language my first question
to you was as a Canadian was there
anything interesting about American
politics that you learned from doing
this film like an Indian nation so and
and anybody explain these concepts to me
simply am very thankful for you both you
both play pretty honorable characters I
was wondering if there's anything you
Envy particularly about your characters
I just hope maybe I brought my own
honesty to the character and I must say
I I may go I pay attention to the news
way too much
people like John Stewart and and others
can talk circles around me politically
you know I know my gut reactions but to
talk really intelligently not too easy
available to watch at home miss June
team
[Applause]
I will never get over singing miss Jim
team clean and totally turquoise Jones
is a single mom who holds down a
household a rebellious teenager and
pretty much everything that goes down at
wayman's bebe human lounge turquoise is
also a beauty queen she was once crowned
Miss Juneteenth a title commemorating
June 19th the day slaves in Texas were
freed two years after the Emancipation
Proclamation life didn't turn out as
beautifully as the title promised but
turquoise determined to write her wrongs
is cultivating her daughter KY to become
Miss Juneteenth even if KY wants
something else also available to watch
it home today surely a little novella
I'm calling none of your goddamn
business a young couple moves in with
horror writer Shirley Jackson and her
college professor husband Stan Lee in
hopes of starting a new life instead
they find themselves in a psychodrama
that inspires Jackson's next major novel
the film was directed by Josephine
Decker who won the author filmmaking
Award at Sundance alright well that's it
for today leave us a comment and let us
know what you'll be watching I'm Cale
anonymous and I will see you next time
[Music]